make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into Doomsday
Clock thank God the newest issue a
Doomsday Clock came out - I didn't even
know if it was gonna happen like dude
this class this story has been so
delayed it's absolutely crazy but it is
really good and it really is kind of
worth it it's pretty amazing like we
finally get answers here right which is
kind of the issue at Jeff Jones is great
at writing but sometimes he stretches
things on a bit too long especially when
it takes a story like three years to
finish that it's just like our age dude
just release it all is like a one-shot
lie just released the rest of it is like
just one trade or something like that
just like one single story anyway so
what we have going on here in this world
right now on in the DC Universe which
remember this is in continuity this is
taking place
I mean before all the stuff that's going
on right now but basically it takes
place in the main DC line of comics you
essentially have the world falling apart
right because the world has learned
about the Superman conspiracy released
the Superman conspiracy has taken hold
in the world and then of course you had
the explosion of Ronnie Raymond in in
Moscow Russia and then you had the
superheroes taking off to Mars so to get
you guys caught up on those of you guys
who aren't really who aren't really
familiar with this first things first go
watch all the other videos that we've
done and the second thing is to do kind
of a rundown like a quick little
explanation here the Superman conspiracy
is this idea that floats around that
after Superman arrived in the world
right like after he basically popped up
and became Superman he left Smallville
went to the Trop alas and became
Superman that what the United States
started doing was basically creating
metahumans of their own they could
either be a counter to Superman or could
fight alongside Superman right it was
basically the United States government's
attempt to kind of maintain control of
the country now following that you have
the events in Moscow and the idea behind
this was that somewhere along the line
Ronnie Raymond and company ended up in
in Moscow Russia now how all that ties
together will actually find out later in
this story but basically Ronnie Raymond
ended up in in Moscow Russia and during
a major conflict he essentially
detonated and when that happened it
basically killed a multitude of
different people essentially turning
them to glass and then people saw it as
an attack by American metahumans on
Russian soil and that basically led to
Russians attending to retaliate against
the United States now following this you
had all the superheroes or at least all
the major superheroes from the US who
went to Mars now they were following the
trail of breadcrumbs which led them to
believe the dr. Manhattan was on Mars
albeit they didn't know who he was they
just knew there was a being out there
and they had basically hypothesis
that he was the one responsible for all
of this the problem was when they went
to go face-off against dr. Manhattan he
toyed with him for about 30 seconds and
then took him all out and that was
basically it right so pretty much all
the superheroes in the United States
except for Wonder Woman Superman and
Batman are basically gone like I mean
they're not dead but they're essentially
unconscious on Mars now because of that
what it does is it picks up with the
fact that the earth is basically
devolved into total chaos right like
what you're seeing right now is
essentially the way that adrian veidt's
world in the Watchmen universe had
essentially gone its way right i mean
Adrian Veidt basically released this
giant monster into the world and with
all the death and all the destruction at
United humanity and then following that
people eventually figured out that
Adrian Veidt was the one behind it that
it was all one big ruse and humanity
actually devolved to his state worse
than before and then ultimately it ended
with the Watchmen universe being
engulfed in nuclear war basically wiping
out all life on Earth at least we can
just kind of assume that was the case
since you know it was nuclear war it was
it was mutually assured destruction
right he was mad so because of that this
really kind of seems to be going the
same way
where like things kind of seemed to be
evolving in the same process you've got
a litany of conflicts taking place right
Lee you've got Giganta facing off
against Wonder Woman and then suddenly
she's met by the arrival of Black Adam
now this is only end up finding out here
that in black Adams country of conduct
because of the fact that he's so
isolationist he's almost kind of taken
this magneto approach now oh really
Black Adam has done this a litany of
times over the years right like I mean
you really saw it a lot in the injustice
stories but basically what what like
Adam has done here is he has isolated
conduct and said this is a safe haven
for metahumans all the metahumans who
were left on earth who are not far like
the top tier superheroes and they can
all come to conduct and they can
basically find like refuge now it does
allow the various metahumans to leave
but the big focus that the United States
has at the moment that is to say the
American people and even people in
Russia and in some other countries
across the world is that the United
States needs the handover Superman and
the reason why is because Vladimir Putin
has issued a deadline line you said at
midnight if Superman is not handed over
to the Russian government
we launch an attack because right now
the United States has no real
superheroes but Russia does Russia has
all their various superhero forces and
so invading the United States would
actually go off pretty much without it
without a hitch and so again like
everything is kind of falling to pieces
because when all that happens you end up
having Superman of course who awakes you
know following you know his incident and
collapsing all the kind of stuff you got
Superman who basically wakes up in two
you know with this I guess
we'll break having been taken with
everything kind of going to pieces with
everything going to pot and it's kind of
a crazy scenario because as that happens
you end up finding out that essentially
that Adrian Veidt is talking to somebody
that we can't really see watching these
things unfold and these makeshift
monitors and everything sort of going to
pieces you know but then of course we
end up finding out that Adrian Veidt is
actually an Arkham Asylum and the way
this whole thing plays out the releases
seems like he's an Arkham Asylum but the
way all this plays out as he walked by
one room tells us old man to be quiet
and then he basically ends up running up
on Saturn girl I remember Saturn girl
was part of the Legion of super-heroes
from the 30th century I think Bend has
changed it to the 31st century but she's
part of the Legion of super-heroes for
the future if she can read minds the
issue is that when she came back here
presumably she came back here to warn of
like a major event that was gonna happen
right that's what adrian veidt's says
like you came here to warn Superman of
something that you can possibly
understand right but the issue is that
somewhere along the line she was
basically captured and she was thrown in
Arkham Asylum at one point we don't know
exactly where she is right now but like
she was essentially captured it wasn't
able to warn Superman now because that
we end up switching over to Lex Luthor
now this is one of the most important
parts of the story right because Lex
Luthor has been working with Lois Lane
to kind of give these little bits and
pieces of information in terms of what
seems to truly be going on here and what
Lex Luthor says is that at some point
along the line that he found a
photograph now we know that this
photograph is of John Rytas of dr.
Manhattan back was he back when he was
human on the watchman universe but this
this photo was brought with dr.
Manhattan over to the main DC Universe
when he arrived and the picture was
discovered the issue with this is that
multitudes of these pictures have been
discovered write it be simple if it was
just one because what that means is that
dr. Manhattan brought the picture with
him and then when he showed up in the
main DC Universe at whatever time frame
then the picture was basically dropped
right by accident or whatever the case
may have been he left it there and that
basically has kind of just been floating
there ever since the issue is that all
these pictures are showing up here right
they're showing up at different points
in time in the DC Universe now really
what geoff johns does it's kind of give
us a hint he won't full-on explain this
until the end but it kind of gives us a
hint right like the big moment is back
in on April 18th in 1938 now the reason
why I say this was a hit this is a hint
is because for those are guys who are
familiar with your DC history
that's when Action Comics number one was
published in the chronological timeline
of DC including all the various crises
and everything they've had
that's when Clark Kent officially like
came out as Superman right like that was
his first major act
Permenter so that was a huge moment in
the history of things you go forward and
you end up finding each one of these
things has appeared at various points in
time now the question seemed to be at
least from from Lois Lane stance does
this mean that like whoever's doing this
is traveling through time now those are
the guys who were familiar with dr.
Manhattan no that's not the case dr.
Manhattan does not time travel right he
can't jump from the future to the past
dr. Manhattan sees all time as a
singular moment right so like he's
standing in like 2019 right he's just
kind of staring vaguely out into space
that's because he's seeing all points in
time simultaneously so it really kind of
knows where things are gonna be but he
doesn't actually go to the future he
still moves forward in time just like
everybody else does but he's not from
this universe so again like this is him
popping up here and so Lex Luthor
actually has his own theory in terms of
how it is that a man that cannot
time-travel somehow appears at different
points in time with the same picture
right because by all standards of
measurement what this looks like is it
looks like dr. Manhattan showed up on
April 13th and 1938 in the main DC
Universe when Superman first popped up
and then seemed to drop the picture or
forget about it or whatever and then
left maybe went to a different universe
or something like that then came back
but it's almost like he basically went
back to the past and then came to the
future and then went back to the past
and then came to a different point in
the future and then rinse repeat right
but we know that's not the case because
Manhattan doesn't time-travel and so
it's cool because we end up getting this
really really good explanation from
Geoff Johns towards the end of this in
terms of how all that goes down and so
really like following this you end up
picking up with reginal long now of
course again wretched along was that the
son of Malcolm long and the guy who's
essentially the new Rorschach here and
while he's being held in prison he
starts experiencing these crazy visions
read these visions of his father going
in to basically speak with Walter corvax
that he's trying to play with him Hey
look don't do that don't be that guy who
does that it's only gonna destroy you
end up meeting with like Johnny Thunder
now of course that happened at some
point before and Johnny Thunder
basically sacrificed his life right he
died he just kind of burned alive but
then you basically end up seeing that
he's actually speaking or at least you
kind of have this appearance of Alfred
Pennyworth now this is kind of a subtle
thing but it's also an exceedingly
important thing and the reason why is
because it's very very short and it
doesn't seem to be important but this
basically solidifies the fact that
Batman has not given up on Rorschach
remember that I was the one that grabbed
him Batman was the one that took him and
basically tossed him in the slammer and
he's kind of been there ever since but
what it means is that Batman didn't
throw him in the slammer and then just
walk away
forget about it the Batman had a back-up
plan the back-up plan was Alfred do your
homework go through here and look at
everything about reginal long read the
whole diary of war Shack the whole nine
yards learn everything you possibly can
given the circumstances right because
the guys from a different universe who
doesn't really have a life on this on
this main DC Universe but learn
everything you can and and see if what
he says is true of course cuz Batman had
everything else going on didn't really
have time for it and that's what
Alfred's been doing Alfred's been doing
research he's been poking around and he
basically learned that everything that
reginal long said is true right like
everything that he's claimed about his
life about war shack the man the old
Walter Kovacs being worshipped before
him that all of that is true he's not
just a crazy guy but the issue is that
where you end up having Alfred
Pennyworth trying to side with him all
that you really have or at least all
that that Reggie really knows at this
point is betrayal
right that's really all he knows about
his life is betrayal losing his father
Ozymandias turning against him Batman
doing him in the slammer that's all he
really knows so of course he ends up
bailing on Alfred Pennyworth and taking
off you know and that's when things
really sort of just kind of vanish and
because what this does is it switches
over to the answer to into an answer to
the question that a lot of people have
been wondering about Doomsday Clock
since the beginning of Doomsday Clock
one of the questions a lot of people
have had is where Sally just Fezzik
whatever her name is like Sally Jupiter
basically and like night owl - were
those characters out and we actually get
an answer here so if you recall the
characters from the previous video
marionette and mom who were basically
just criminals right they were -
street-level criminals and that at some
point in their past when they were
committing a robbery that dr. Manhattan
was going to killed him but then chose
not to because of the fact that
marionette was pregnant now what
Ozymandias says here is that when this
went down everybody believed that dr.
Manhattan didn't kill marionette because
of the fact that she was pregnant but
then he started thinking literally dr.
Manhattan stood there and watch the
comedian kill a pregnant woman so like
he doesn't really care about the notion
of pregnancy like the significance of it
or anything like that it's just a human
he doesn't really care anything about
who was also housing a smaller human who
doesn't really he doesn't really care
anything about so the question was why
did he save marionette and the reason
why is because at some point along the
line marionette would give birth to
their daughter and then either they
would die or they would end up in jail
or she would have to give it up or
whatever the case says but the child
would be handed over to Sally just
Fezzik and to dan dreiberg who have
basically adopted the monikers of Hollis
now that was a that was a very end of
the Watchmen that was part of the
Watchmen story but essentially like they
adopt a new idea
and then went forward is wholly new
people now the downside of this is we
can largely assume that they basically
died in the Watchmen universe right when
the world was engulfed in nuclear war
that was basically the end of it but
that's what ends up happening here with
with Ozymandias is he basically starts
to break down all this bit of a story
starts to explain all these different
things and what he says here is that on
his world that it all basically engulfed
he was trying to find a way to unite it
right then he was trying to find a way
to save his world once everybody
realized that he was basically pulling a
ruse that he's the one who released the
monster that he managed didn't actually
unite itself because of some genuine
threat from a different dimension or
from outer space or however they wanted
to interpret it instead like they were
all manipulated by Ozymandias and so as
a result of this what he wanted to do
was basically save his world which was
rapidly devolved in a nuclear war which
we can largely assume by now is it's
already too late for it and at the same
time like try to find a way to save this
world which would ultimately end up
devolve into the same landscape and so
what he did is he manipulated this world
in order to save it that when he went
out and when he started poking around
and he started looking around what he
ended up discovering is that one when he
grabbed this ship and when he stowed
away and then he jumped from his
universe to this universe then as he
started going around and looking around
he discovered of course superheroes he
discovered like the flash and Wonder
Woman and Batman as Shazam and all these
characters which seemed exceedingly
impossible right I mean it is a
different universe from his own and so
if the DC if DC Comics can have a
universe for anthropomorphic animals
including Captain carrot captain Herrick
I love captain carrot captain cares
super bunny if you can have a universe
that basically has anthropomorphic
animals playing the role of superheroes
then you can have a universe where you
have humans who are superheroes right
like an infinite number of universes for
an infinite number of possibilities
which seemingly only 52 have actually
been discovered according to Grant
Morrison's Multiversity and so because
of that what he did is he said okay fine
there's a way to manipulate everything
there's a way to basically get Manhattan
to come back and so what he did here is
seemingly in the blink of an eye he
engineered this plant that when he
started looking around he learned that
the Superman conspiracy actually had
mirrored that while it wasn't like not
every single metahuman in the United
States is a result of government
experimentation some of them are under
Martin Stein basically the guy who would
go on to merge with Ronnie Raymond and
become firestorm that under Martin Stein
all these projects were seen they were
over seemed and they were basically
designed to create metahumans thank you
either counter Superman or fight along
and monitor Superman Riley was basically
the US government never
we trusted the Man of Steel and so they
wanted to have at least some kind of a
deterrent right that Superman was
basically a really really cool guy and
then Lois Lane broke his heart and he
said you know what the heck with
humanity way like he followed the red
pill and just became this really angry
guy and then basically like tried to
wipe away the world then they would have
a way to counter that right and so
because of that but what he did is he
said okay then let's take the Superman
conspiracy and Leslie get to a guy named
named named pose art out in in Russia
writes and then Russia gets a hold of
the Superman conspiracy before the US
does and then Russia starts espousing it
and so that's why you ended up having
this initial rift in the United States
because Russia was saying that the
United States is creating all these
various superheroes in response to
Superman then the Superman conspiracy is
real and the American people initially
rejected it right it was just Russians
using misinformation and just doing what
they do but then detailed information
started to leak out and as that
information started to leak out humanity
began to believe it and as they started
to believe it they started to turn
against Superman following this
Ozymandias engineered the explosion of
firestorm in Russia which further seemed
to lead to the idea that if the United
States government is engineering
superheroes for the purpose of doing
whatever is they want to do and then
Russia called them on it Russia leaked
that information this is the US
government retaliating against Russia or
it's the superheroes retaliating against
Russia whatever the case is it looks
like it's the United States acting in a
defensive manner because what Russia
said was true and so it further
solidified the Superman conspiracy and
then further solidified people turning
against Superman and the various members
of the superhero community and so when
all this is basically explained we end
up having this really really cool
exchange that takes place between one
Superman and black Adam as well as
Ozymandias and Jupiter girl that Jupiter
girl Saturn girl against Mars girl uh so
the way this plays out of course is you
basically have like Black Adam Ennis
forces would show up on the White House
lawn right which never bodes well like
any time that the Black Adam shows up it
usually means somebody's gonna get the
crap beat out of them right it's usually
way this so you end up having this kind
of exchange here right now Superman
shows up because regardless of what the
world thinks of him Superman will
continue to protect the world now that's
the nature of his character it's the way
he's always been written that Superman's
role his his loyalty is not to like a
singular government to man's not loyal
to the US government any more so than he
would be loyal to the Russian government
or anything like that if it's something
that would endanger people like he'll
side with the government if they need
him to do something that would basically
like stop some some catastrophic threat
right like the US government comes to
mitts
Superman there is a meteor coming to
earth and it's gonna destroy all life on
Earth we need you to work alongside the
Suicide Squad and stop it okay then like
he would do that but like he's not a
government stooge this is not like the
Dark Knight Returns where he just does
what the government tells him to instead
it's basically one of these things where
he's an ally of Earth and having having
like black Adam show up on the White
House lawn to confront the president is
basically a scenario that goes with
Superman saying somebody has to act but
this is a problem with the Superman
conspiracy right you know in in this day
and age it's you know people choose the
facts they want right like people
believe what they want to believe and so
because of that people would look at
that and they would say well it's not
really Superman standing and like
protecting the president if Superman
protecting the government because he's a
government stooge because of the
Superman conspiracy because you know I I
believe it's true I want it to be true
so I'm going to assume it's true and and
it's interesting is it's really kind of
a social critique rather it's a critique
on modern society
right like people replace facts with
their opinions and then treat their
opinions as fact and so it's it's kind
of interesting you know in terms of how
this unfolds but you end up having
Ozymandias who basically asked this
question to Saturn girl he says here's
the question that I have for you if you
come from the future of this timeline
and in the future of this timeline a
massive event takes place and you've
come damn warned Superman because of it
here's my question
does Superman remember you right like
does he does he like in the in in
whatever this future is does Superman
remember you and the response to that
question is no and so basically she
starts to vaporize because what what
Ozymandias basically says is you come
from a timeline that doesn't exist
anymore right you come from a timeline
that's not there anymore
this feeds into what dr. Manhattan had
basically discovered is that by virtue
of his actions the Legion of
super-heroes don't exist right a legion
of super-heroes ceased to exist because
of something that it is that he's done
and so as you end up having Ozymandias
passing by this this cell with his old
man we end up learning this old man is
actually Alan Scott he's the Green
Lantern which is a crazy revelation that
seemingly Alan Scott seems to be still a
lot like I don't really know how as far
as I'm aware he's dead that wound up
happening is is in one of the earlier
Doomsday Clock stories the dr. Manhattan
had actually moved the lantern away from
Alan Scott so that when the lantern
landed Alan Scott didn't see it and was
hit by the train
instead of in the original comic when he
saw the Lantern crash and then he went
to go grab the lantern and because he
grabbed it he and either he wasn't hit
by the train right he missed the train
and so because of that like it's kind of
a crazy little a little facet here
because you end up
Manhattan watching this whole scenario
unfold with Superman fighting against
like Adam and he says like in six
seconds Superman is going to see me five
four three two one
Superman meets dr. Manhattan with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become a part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace